so you leave
um you go and start your own uh new life
are you following everything with the
story with the plans of wanting to
retaliate against oday and if yes how
did you
okay here first of all
if i go back nearly 30 years back
one i don't write any book
two i'll be disappeared three
i don't be in the media four i never say
anything
about my ex life and i live my life and
i have
my passport my great family
my this since the book
i wrote it and i start in the media
my life demolished up till now i'm
talking
to you i don't have a life
even saddam gun even by afghan
even saddam or the gun
but another chapter starts with
another government in here right now
exactly wars what they did to me
since saddam fell i have four death
penalty
issued by this new regime in iraq
why i was dreaming what intel do you
what intel do you have that scares them
that concerns them
hey i have a mouth and i know them and
those people it was the same team of
iraqi opposition i know up and down of
those guys
what the guy he was driving my kids
omar 27 years ago to school
he become prime minister you imagine in
iraq
then another one she was a chef cooking
at my house she became third secretary
in iraq and that's in holland
you know everyone out of my house you
become leader now
a people you know brahimi jafari this
guy what he become second prime minister
in iraq
he's registered in london he's a
psychopath
he went to the social worker
excuse me pm himself because
they cut his 100 pound of rent
and now 6
billion pound here on in britain
6 million pound and this is a small fish
and when i talk maybe you visit my
channel on youtube
you know this is six channel verified
channel
they shut it down for me 1.2 million
follower on youtube verify channel uh
page one tick gun
one and a half million in facebook
switch off
they buying people they buy in people
because they don't want to hear their
dirt what i know about them
and i do life always i do life now with
with my follower even my enemy
they start following me and telling me
you're telling the truth
you know truth is horde truth
is horde those guys what running
iraq make me personally
and this is first time i will say that
make me feel so sorry
i was opposition to saddam hussein
compare saddam to those guys he's a
prophet
coming from allah or god i'll call him
what he called
compared to these guys saddam he didn't
kill
in 35 years what those people killed in
the past 17 years
saddam he was running the country
up and down and you have every month
food
he got your local shop you get it for
free
he was running iraq 10 billion
pounds okay a year
now 130 billion
uh dollar i say a year
half of the nation living from rubbish
they don't have food
17 years of democracy
no alchemicity no water no education
no medical health no system no nothing
absolutely
nothing we have mosul gun
destroyed as a flat land now
but the muscle of history
every sunni area has been destroyed
and not against anybody not a religion
no anything
nothing i never talk religion because
for me
religion is destroying of mind
no matter which way i never talk
religion
or believe in this or that i believe
what here
i believe what i see i believe what i
read
and after that i make my mind you don't
come to me and tell me 1400 years ago
something happened
where is your proof the story we can't
tell story
those people and they are not even shia
you know they saying they are shia but
for me no i have a lot of
friends here they are nice people they
are educated people they are
they don't have this hate for other
people
you know i have so much iranian friend
i have a friend from japan from
everywhere and though i
never look at the person which religion
or background coming
you know for you because sometimes when
when you know anytime we do interviews
with anybody we
we we will typically do extensive
research and the team will get a lot of
data and we'll contact some people some
of the people will say
some of the stories you say you over
exaggerate
and it didn't have you know you haven't
say yeah they're fake
they're not real it didn't happen you
waited for them to die until you told
the story when uday died and then you
came up
so some of the people are saying that
about you what do you say to people that
say
none of these things you talk about are
true you've made up what do you say to
them
three newspapers wrote this three of
they're a friend to each other one he
starts
he's in ireland he's not a journalist
two nothing to do with journalism
three when he wrote the article
to the guardian in britain
he wrote it as opinion if you go
search of this guy background
he bagged me in ireland to come and want
to review with me
and i welcome him to my home what is not
easy for me to bring somebody to go home
but this guy he's been paid to something
do it one he's not a journalist he write
a small line and local paper
about a new pubs opening area a new
restaurant open
and i wrote a full article on my website
about him
but at the time give me one
whole world from trump to
smallest person in the world not being
humiliated by media
if he's you know no one
or he have enemy or have you know
jealousy killed sometime
when they saying lot if nobody heard
about him till
he wait a day and because i die and let
it come on
out no in 1993 my facebook comment out
in vienna by
norcifer lag was a book
thousand page okay
1993 this is 10 years early of odeon
jose
yeah when the book come out i get the
first assassination attempt i think
few weeks later second assassination
attempt was a bomb
under my car and everything has been
documented by the australian
intelligence service
but they don't want to say it why
because
was an agenda between iraq and two
countries
financially was at the time controlling
austria was iran
and iraq you know there was control
the intelligence service they have
everything
in vienna you know was iranian
government
and iraqi government at the time
all the iraqi embassies after the second
goal for the invasion of kuwait
has been shut down except two one in
switzerland
and one in vienna was international uh
[Music]
law and they close everything they don't
have anything
and i was fighting okay
in 1994 i did the assassination attempt
in 1995 i get assassination attempt
and 19 in march 1995
i come to london running from australia
i've been shot here but the bullet
doesn't come to me was
one of my guys again
oh they personally called me i was
wishing
at the time in 95 like we have this
technology can record by the phone you
know
he said to me 3rd of july
1995 your dad is here and my office
if you don't stop you never see your dad
again
there you go this is your dad
i talked to my dad the one word say to
me
god make my life god he take it not this
[ __ ]
okay this brave man
fourth of july next day after 12 hours i
think no more on that
my father was killed
i paid the price until now i'm eating
myself
because of that but again
were those people was okay
when i sit we can't say media
can be full right media they have the
resources
and half of the media they have very
good connection with intelligent servers
that is not intelligent service police
secret service i don't know what
correct how can what if you're here
for the world from 92
up to 2003 right
to how can lot if you're here sit
and make up this story
if you read the book i wrote it in 1992
correct if i wasn't inside this
how i know every nails were in the
palace
i described the past exactly how
i lived in it correct who can go
and this wall to saddam palace and live
there
correct you can't drive even
outside the palace and bug that how can
i be inside and describe
all these what inside the palace
and the secret and everything and all
that
intelligent service here in the west
they say to me
oh now we found because an article or
two somebody wrote about you
second journalist at caesar
at caesar contract producing company
when
we was filming in malta who's at caesar
he's a friend with this guy in an island
okay he told him if you read the article
ex-wife x-ma i don't know what okay
give me one x if she was good
she don't be x correct
if she is x she got to talk good about
love if you're here
no correct she got to fabricate a story
and say story and like that
but again i answer even she's my
ex because i don't like the drugs
because i don't like somebody stealing
from my bank account
because i don't like somebody sit
having sex in my house and my bed
when i'm traveling for business and when
i catch them
okay this is what's happened
this is the irish police